he needs no introduction come on the man
who's changing the music game in my
opinion little by little it's working I
just saw Dizzy Wright post something
today about how he just dropped his
project and like uh 200 fans supported
it I think on the same platform you're
using even even and uh the crazy thing
is is he showed the Stream
equivalency and that to me I think is
like I think it was like in his first
day it was like the money he made was
like 1.4 million streams worth of money
right which is crazy because you know
these companies are [__] everybody
hey you
know it's a tough topic cuz they're not
[__]
everyone like streaming is an extra
Revenue but people are treating it like
it's the main one is that fair to say
exactly and that's the issue it's like
bro they really created something
revolutionary like I'm I'm grateful for
streaming I get paid monthly off some
[__] that I typically L you feel me but
it's like I I get people's that SCP but
it's like man they were trying to do
something and they did do something
Innovative and game changing it's like
we didn't tell all these [__] to give
up their main sources of revenue yeah we
didn't tell y to stop selling decided to
do that collectively randomly it's like
bro why aren't you selling your [__]
music because you don't have real fans
just like you would sell a t-shirt or
any other product you should be selling
your music too mhm yeah know I just had
to talk with uh Queen niga who was up
here she's on a major label and I was
like yo you got like a vinyl or you know
tape or anything or she's like no
actually I just talked to the label
about that I'm like you got like real
fans you'll sell a thousand of those in
a week real fans like what are we doing
like it's it is crazy though cuz like
you said like I saw somebody it was it
you it might have been you or it might
have been uh
somebody had just brought up the
idea
of using
streaming as a commercial for your music
taking it off like a trailer type [__]
like yo you'll see how crazy my alas for
a month but then it's gone right now you
got to go buy it which is kind of like
the opposite of what you know I think
people have been doing right yeah I mean
I don't I don't think you have to
neglect the market like leave your [__]
on streaming but allow people who want
to purchase your product to purchase it
from you too you feel me like you don't
have
to you don't have to like revolt against
something and take all your [__] away
cuz you're stealing revenue from
yourself you're not hurting them you're
stealing from your cuz they're not going
nowhere yeah yeah and and also you're
hurting the opportunity to be discovered
new marketing streaming is a form of
marketing it's like you throw all of
your [__] in a pool and someone may pick
that [__] up to where now they want to
spend money with you they want to go to
your shows they want to buy merch they
want to buy whatever you got to offer
they want to buy stock they want to buy
go-karts like your streaming is just
marketing that you get paid for right
that's fair um so give me uh what's the
update with you man I haven't seen you
uh since I was at your house which was
yeah it was hot outside I just remember
that right it was hot as [__] that was a
great show too it was an amazing show
you had shooter gang Coney out there uh
what was the 16-year-old kid's name you
Molly he was he came up here came up
here yeah he so fire him and his dad
came he six School yep yeah shout out to
Modesto necessary man shout out Merced
Merced Modesto Merced God damn it no not
the same not the same somewhere over
there kind of over there they're not too
far from each
other they might are they are they far
oh
[__] wait noest sh out Merc though wait
Modesto's like by I'm tripping hey man
these little California cities confuse
me but no it was it was a a special day
man it was really dope um
your dad was making food right your mom
was getting me high right um I got to
check out just like your office and your
at home studio and how you kind of
schedule your social media post with
your team it was just it was an
inspiring situation because everybody I
brought with me at some point in time
either artist or you know my producer he
was shooting but he also was an artist
and a a a a beat maker and engineer so
it was just dope for everybody to see
like there's another way right that I
love the backyard shows cuz you get to
see uh so many creatives in motion not
just my team it be other [__] filming
for their own interviews and podcast
just like it's a pool of creativity that
you get to witness and I think uh a TV
show was there that day one of the big
networks was shooting that day or was it
was CNN CNN CNN y yeah it was dope man
but what's what so obviously you've been
killing it I've been seeing a lot of
your uh you know since since then I've
watched you on a bunch of platforms
talking about the movement but what is
the latest um what's going on with L
Russell man uh
man the compound so much the way right
it's it's a ton of [__] the compound is
something I'm really excited about um we
building like an artist creative and
Wellness Center so it got a a merch
distribution and production facility um
editing Bay editing lab I'm building
like a live venue inside of it for real
intimate shows like a 100 cap low lowkey
[__] um and then we got the content
Studio that we moving over from our shop
and then our old shop we're turning into
to like a creative Hub that our network
will be able to rent and utilize to do
all their creative needs um yeah [__]
just building so people are going to be
able to like if they want to put music
out if they want to get a video done
they could go you could kind of be
onetop shop if I need to get my merch
ran right it's a One-Stop shop but it's
not like um it's for Network like I'm
building infrastructure so when I find
artist like shant's over there someone
knew that we're we're helping cultivate
and she's like and incredible so when I
find artists that I really love it's
just like it's easy to integrate them
into a system and we start seeing the
following grow immediately and we just
know what to do so we built all the
infrastructure so we don't have to take
someone there there there there there to
get the result it's crazy because it's I
I you know I I feel like Russ was the OG
guy who was like telling the truth to
rappers but they were like Russ is a
dick right I feel like your message has
been a lot more palatable right you've
inspired I'm sure people you don't even
know you've inspired at this point man
[__] be crazy like big artist I'm
talking about superstars I'm sure
because your content has been
digested labels use my blueprint like if
there's there's there's not too many
offices who don't know who I am and what
I'm doing and telling their and they all
hate on you when I bring listen can I be
honest with you right please all of
these industry guys cuz I bring your
name up all the [__] time they all
are hating on you right I'm telling you
they all say the said yeah but but he
ain't got like a like a hit like what's
where's the music and I'm like what like
this happens this I promise
you that a version of that
conversation's happened at least 20
times you what's crazy too is like um
and I'm talking about people in your
city people in your city I have ton man
I got I know I got tons of songs and
like the the difference is the amount of
money that you're able to put behind a
record like [__] don't understand
[__] be on on label deals and in
contract
and I got a million followers and made
millions of dollars and they haven't but
[__] are talking about oh you ain't
got a
hit well you do and you still don't have
what I have you feel me like that [__]
don't be making sense and adding up it's
ego it's ego it's because they can't do
it so they go resort to that I had
someone I was talking to um someone from
a label and I was telling them like
we're about to scale to this next level
he was like man I think if you just kind
of um if you if you work on the music
side y y
and I was just like do you hear the [__]
that's blowing up there's not one artist
right now who can make her do that
little dance a family business some of
these songs I've made is like [__] do
you hear what we talk there's no rap
artist who's doing what the [__] I'm
doing and you [__] talking about some
music to me with all the stupid [__] we
hear blowing up it's like y'all in y'all
are insane and the whole industry is
like delusion know and Faking It these
[__] don't like these songs that's
being pushed and that's on the radio and
that's getting exposed no they don't
listen to them in car they don't listen
to them at home you feel me but
everybody's rallying behind this [__]
and acting like we we we really it's
just weird and everyone has a
job right and that's what I've learned
so all of the people we're talking about
our employed exactly and and it is in
their best interest to keep their
employment status J to push whatever
comes across my autonomy this long like
bro was just saying before he wed out he
like man youve been holding out and it's
like I haven't even been holding out I'm
just
unimpressed that's fair